hey everyone welcome back to another
episode of ranking
a big thank you to warby parker for
sponsoring this episode
orbee parker is committed to providing
exceptional vision care online
and in stores they have some amazing
eyeglasses sunglasses and they also
offer eye exams and contact lenses
glasses start at just 95 bucks including
prescription lenses
and they also have blue light lenses and
progresses available too
you can try warby parker's free home try
on program where you order five pairs of
glasses to try it at home for free for
five days with no obligation to buy send
whatever you don't want back
they ship free and it includes a
pre-paid return shipping label
if you need help choosing frames you can
take their quiz you answer a few quick
questions and they'll suggest some great
looking frames that are totally
personalized fit your face
and your style one thing i really like
about
warby parker is the quality of their
frames they definitely feel premium and
they're super
comfortable go to warbyparker.com
jubilee to try on your five pairs for
free
at home and as always enjoy the episode
and thanks for watching
i'm not saying that it's not cute
because you're rocking a girl fire but
i would be caught then i mean that's
okay you're entitled to your own
boring opinion
[Music]
everyone looks good yeah we're all super
cute
yeah came with the fits um well
how do you guys want to start this all
how do we feel
looking at me okay i'll go first i'm
inspired by y2k like i love
barbie i better not be wearing these
heels for nothing because my feet are
numb
so i better be number one it's funny
that you mentioned barbie because as
soon as i saw you i was like bomb barbie
like i know
that's everything i've ever wanted okay
but i'm pretty sure
this outfit is fire yeah i know i really
like your outfit it just like it seems
very like sustainable and like i've
never seen that before
so this is a coffin purse which is like
super cute to me because i got it in a
costume shop
i like rabbit a lot and i'm confident
but i don't know i'm not i don't like
i'm too like i guess i'd be like okay
listen up i'm number one
and you're not gonna bow down um so i
would put myself like middle to top
i think that my style can come off
intimidating a little bit because it's
like kind of dark and kind of opposite
of my personality
but i like the aesthetic i like a bit of
steampunk a bit of victorian with the
corset
um you're really committed to what you
have with your outfit
i personally think i should be at least
at one or two because
i really am confident my style for me
that's kind of like this old hollywood
vintagey
kind of style and that's what i really
enjoy i wanted to showcase my style and
i wanted to see
if anyone out there could relate to
something that i could wear
the classic look isn't dead and if you
if you feel like you can rock it then
rock it
since i'm already at number one i'ma
just stay here i'm kidding um my fit
honestly i was like i don't know what
pants to wear so i
decided not to wear any because the camo
i definitely was thinking that i had to
go above and beyond thinking that this
had to be
the world's best outfit but i had to
step back and think like what would i
wear on a daily basis so that people can
get an idea of what i do wear the bag
specifically i got because it's black
owned i want to support black artists
um black businesses and all that above
this is so well done the colors just go
so well together you're definitely a
streetwear girl okay
i'll say number one number two number
three
in the plaid number four coffin number
five
y2k barbie i mean that's okay you're
entitled to your own
boring opinion don't get me wrong it's
really hard to just go but
not saying that it's not cute because
you're rocking a girl fire but
i would be caught then like i would just
be walking around like
don't look at me like i don't know it's
just it's cute but not my taste
totally you're gonna laugh when i say
this because it's so like
not normal but i feel like my outfit
today is so boring
so i feel like i kind of toned it down a
little bit because i was like maybe i
shouldn't show up in like a full ball
gown
our side taste is like kind of similar
in the same universe yeah like
barbie and then like regular barbie so i
would put haley first
i would put isa second i would put
myself third
and then i would put in a fourth and i
would put lex fifth i put myself first
without
ever standing arrogant we've got issa is
two
three is celeste four is
lex and five is haley okay so i would
put myself in number one
of course i think that this is just like
the pinnacle of
style definitely not to everyone but for
me
tacky queen over here i would put
celeste number two
i would put issa number three i would
put lex number four
and i'll put anna number five well for
me i would put myself one
two i would put lex because this is an
outfit i would definitely wear as well
probably tomorrow
like give me yeah and then third i would
definitely put celeste
fourth i would put haley fifth i would
put you ando but
i mean it's just not my style but i
think you look really great in it though
yeah so i think i got the most
threes i got like four or five and like
i got like ones or twos i just i think
i'm not gonna move easter
first exactly yeah i think she said
yeah this is like handmade bro like
that's that's another thing i would move
celeste
yeah yeah i actually used to go higher
am i fine am i fine at two i personally
like you at two
how people see me it's like you either
love me or you hate me and then
50 50 i'm just like right in the middle
yeah i don't want to be number 30 but
like it makes sense
i'm fine with this i'll take it
i wasn't satisfied satisfied but i i
mean personally that i was last
but at the same time it said a lot about
just our society and how
we view fashion and i did appreciate
seeing that perspective
especially from other young people like
myself
can you put on your earmuffs
[Music]
all right so we're gonna do this ranking
yeah we're gonna use ranking is one
going to stay in one i think
right no yeah no no really no what
i think one flight yeah one is fine okay
wait let's go down the line to see
like one thing or like a few things
about each person down the line and
we'll keep doing that yes i
kind of like obviously pay attention to
like the little details and i think
that's kind of what i'm judging
my my rankings off of and i really like
zebra print like i like everything
that's put together so i would i would
keep her at number one
can you can you show your purse can you
yeah that hits for me that does it you
know black owned brand she's flexing i
like it she got the boots on like it's
it's the intentionalities the style that
it's it for me but i would put zebra a
second it could have been like elevated
with like
like bigger shoes like platform shoes
the pants wouldn't hit the floor so
okay i like i want to accentuate the
pants uh number two for me
honestly because like i like androgynous
looks um i could wear that
i could wear that entire fade it looks
it's so like clean
if you really like look at the details
and thought that she put behind that
outfit
it was so cohesive you know i'm actually
not a big fan of the pants right i like
everything
stuff like i like yeah yeah the ones are
cool i like like barbie's outfit just
because it
definitely stands out like it definitely
pops and she fits it i don't like the
dress personally
i mean it stands out i mean like i'm
standing outside you know i just really
don't i don't like the print
it looks like a photo yeah okay so i
would put her as
at four the barbie girl she was super
out there in my opinion
it was just more like okay that's a
little too much for me
or i really like that for some reason
even though i i wouldn't normally
like it's like attractive and then with
the you know like coffin purse and the
rings and everything i think is cool the
aesthetic of boots's
outfit is a lot better than barbies i
wish there was like another club
really i think the glove kind of feels
yeah yeah
i guess i think it is if you had two
gloves like gloves are boring
five i saw her fit and i was kind of
like i didn't i didn't think she was in
it i thought she was a part of like the
team
yeah she gives me like like teacher kind
of vibes yes
it just looked too much like mary
poppins for me and i
did i just couldn't get into it like she
could add it more
like a trench coat or something like
that like
that that's her style she was saying
like the vintage
vibes so like it fits it fits the vibe
totally and i understand what she's
going for
that's crazy because you guys are
co-workers
i would definitely think that he was
going to put her at three or something
no
that's me number one
but you don't know what what type of
people i'm into no right in fact
they have to stay number one and two
yeah that's gold and silver
i think it looks like white vessels
might be one yeah yeah one
out of everybody yeah well i said white
vs4 all the guys tended to love
white vest and i was like i get it
but it also seemed like it was missing a
little something for me i'm gonna put a
cigarette too
i would put zebra too also i wouldn't
put it i mean
she has to be too though okay
i think black dress just did a little
bit more who she reminds me of is harley
quinn
that's what i was trying to think of the
whole time so yeah i think z2 should
switch yeah they can switch yeah are you
guys cool with that
yeah yeah yeah i think that's good yeah
i like i like this
yeah i think this is a safe way to go
there yeah
[Music]
so i kind of thought like you guys are
gonna be like yeah she's hot like put
her up front
but they're gonna be like she's way too
much like she's extra put her in the
back so i'm not surprised
i went through phases where i had short
buzzed hair i dressed like a skater boy
and now that i'm in you know this i'm
settled into my like adult style
i get criticized now on the other side
of the spectrum so it used to be oh
you're too masculine
and now it's almost oh you're too
feminine i would have liked to place
higher but at the same time i'm
weirdly proud that i didn't because if i
place last
by the girls and the guys then that's
kind of saying like i'm not everyone's
cup of tea but
there's a certain amount of people that
i can really relate to and i can form a
solid solid peer group rather than
trying to appeal to everyone all the
time
it's okay we're not ready to eat for
you shouldn't be everybody because at
the end of the day as long as you're
happy with what you're wearing and then
you're
super confident go ahead go on with your
days i like that everyone's style is so
different yeah
yeah and it's like we're all fired so
like you know we're all creating like
the best of the best of the outfits i
wear whatever the heck i want to and
then everyone else has to deal with it
i feel like he probably like blows those
with cigars
like giving me like a very like
expensive vibe when you hear best
dressed
obviously you guys are going to think oh
i'm going to wear a suit it's just a
little bit predictable to me
you